his first corinthians chapter 6 verses 9
and 10 a clear prohibition of same
gender married relationships that's the
question I want to dive into today in
our current series titled Hawaii I'm a
gay affirming Christian my name is Brett
Solberg pastor at the table the church
in Sachse Texas and it's such a
privilege to welcome you to Table Talk
where each week I bring you ideas and
insights from Christian theology
spirituality culture that just help you
become a more thoughtful insightful and
hopefully a wonderful human being so
this is part four of our series and like
I mentioned I want to unpack another
passage from the Bible that sometimes
referred to as one of the quote clobber
passages because the way it's often been
used to intellectually clobber LGBTQ
people so to speak so let's go ahead in
here what first Corinthians chapter 6
verses 9 and 10 has to say writes do you
not know that the wrongdoers will not
inherit the kingdom of God do not be
deceived neither fornicators idolaters
adulterers male prostitutes sodomites
thieves the greedy drunkards revilers
guessing that's bad and not totally sure
the revilers or robbers will inherit the
kingdom of God okay so the two key terms
here in greek which of course is what
the Bible was written in the New
Testament not English not even the King
James I know while it is the two terms
are malik oi which translates to male
prostitute second is the term arsenic oi
tie which the NRSV translates as
sodomite other translations use the term
homosexual now for the sake of length
I won't delve into the controversy
surrounding Malik Oi since there's no
real well it's not real controversy
there's some scholarly questions or
controversy but not like among average
Christians about the idea that sexuality
without any restraint ie
prostitution is bad that's not like a
big debate so with that in mind let me
turn my attention to the term arsenic
white I translated and this
version as some might know what does our
cynical wait times mean well literally
it means man bed it's a combination of
two Greek words are sin us which means
male or man in Quetta which is bed so
you put them together and there you go
man Ben now you say it's sort of a weird
term and yes I agree and honestly it's
not one that really shows up in other
ancient writings outside of the Apostle
Paul and or I should say just Paul but
but really the the Bible and
specifically in the Greek version so
because of this a number of more
traditionalist scholars have argued that
Paul as are trying to kind of discern
what he says term mean you know man bet
that it's kind of vague that so they've
argued that perhaps Paul and using this
term or maybe even coining this term
that he might have the Greek translation
of the Old Testament in specifically
Leviticus chapter 20 verse 13 in mind
when you use this word you see in the
Greek version of the latest twenty you
might recall from my last video that
says you know if a man lies with the man
is what the woman she would put to death
so in that passage in Greek you have the
terms are sent us mail going to bed so
certain conservative scholars will say
ah ok so perhaps Paul is he's penny in
first Corinthians chapter 6 verse 9
maybe he's drawing from the male bed
language of Leviticus 20 now to that I
would say yeah perhaps perhaps I mean
granite it is always a bit sketchy to
say things like now what Paul really had
in mind and then act super confident
about that now having said that I think
what other scholars for example Robin
Scroggs point out is that later rabbis
also use the Hebrew version of arsenic
we tie in but when they used it they
were referring specifically to the
active partner in a pederast ik
relationship pederasty that
man-boy love i mean this is basically
like pedophilia and so what this shows
is the challenge of using the history of
a word as definitive proof of its
meaning at a later date in other words
even if you break down or cynically tie
into its two root words and then say see
you see they tie you back in Leviticus
you still have to wrestle with the fact
that later rabbis use the Hebrew version
of that same term to refer to man-boy
love which honestly that interpretation
would seem to a line or be more in favor
of an LGBTQ affirming position in other
words to try and sort of sum this up you
sort of have to make an interpretive
decision with the term Arsenic we time
if you tie the term back in Leviticus
chapter 18 then you start to form an
argument saying hey I think that you
know condemns that sort of the New
Testament can use in the Old Testament
to condemn modern forms of shame same
gender sexuality however if you tie it
into the way the later rabbis use the
term well then you would argue or sent a
court out oh that that's talking abouts
condemning pedophilia which obviously is
not the same thing as modern gay adult
relationships among peers in other words
like imagine you're a modern Bible
interpreter and you've got to translate
this term arsenic oi tie do you choose a
term like homosexual or sodomite
thinking Leviticus 18 or do you choose
to say pedophile like obviously that's a
huge interpretive decision and yet the
truth is that in the end it's really
difficult to venture more than an
educated guess as to what exactly Paul
was referring to in this passage since
we honestly don't have many other uses
of the word in ancient literature or
barely even in Paul's writings so here's
how the scholar Marty nice scene and
kind of sums it up he says the question
of the exact meaning of the
juxtaposition Malakoff and arsenic oi
tes thus remains obscure he says this is
especially the case regarding the word
arsenic oi ty he continues the modern
concept of home
sexuality should by no means be read
into Paul's text nor can we assume that
Paul's words in first Corinthians 6:9
therefore condemn all homosexual
relations in all times in places in ways
he says the meaning of the words are too
vague to justify his claim and Paul's
words should not be used for
generalizations that go beyond this
experience and world in quote so as you
can see saying really confidently that
like 1st Corinthians 6 9 and 10 it says
sodomites or homosexuals shout out here
at the Kingdome in so there before the
Bible said it says it and that settles
it for me it's actually we aren't really
sure what that meant and instead I think
what this shows is sort of the theme of
my last few videos that because the
Bible was written in a very different
time and culture we just have to be
careful of saying I know what this says
definitively when the truth is more
complicated than we thought
and by the way for those wondering the
entire argument I just unpacked it would
also apply to the passage first Timothy
chapter 1 verse 10 which also includes
the term arsenic which I and a long list
of bad things so all that in mind that
is all for today if you enjoyed this
video please go ahead comment below and
ensure you don't miss future episodes go
ahead and subscribe to my youtube
channel or podcasts the most anywhere
podcasts are offered my searching
bretzel fir'd Tabletalk
I love you all grace peace